warum gibt es überhaupt unser universum
warum existieren wir aktuelle
experimente am europäischen
kernforschungszentrum cern versuchen der
wohl spannendsten fragen der modernen
physik auf die schliche zu kommen dabei
wurde die masse von protonen und
antiprotonen auf einen 16 billionstel
genau verglichen also was wurde dabei
herausgefunden klicks im science and
future gibt es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen warum haben sich
materie und antimaterie beim urknall
nicht ausgelöscht warum existieren wir
überhaupt es sind tatsächlich die
wirklich großen fragen die bei den
experimenten am europäischen
kernforschungszentrum cern endlich
gelöst werden soll es handelt sich also
um die suche nach dem ursprung unserer
existenz doch jetzt steht fest beim
baron anti barrio symmetrie experiment
base ist eine absolute rekord messung
gelungen es handelt sich um die
genaueste messungen überhaupt von
protonen und antiprotonen deren massen
konnten tatsächlich auf 11 stellen nach
dem komma verglichen werden das ist ein
großer erfolg dennoch gibt es auch eine
schlechte nachricht die existenz unseres
universums bleibt weiter rätselhaft was
heißt das genau und wie genau gelangen
dem forschungsteam die
rekordverdächtigen messungen sind nun
alle hoffnungen zerschlagen endlich eine
antwort auf die frage zu bekommen warum
unser universum eigentlich existiert
alle super spannenden infos zu diesem
thema gibt es jetzt hier von mir die
ergebnisse des space experiment am cern
offenbaren dass das standardmodell hält
klammheimlich hatten sicherlich viele
physikerinnen und physiker weltweit
gehofft dass diese experimente das
standardmodell der physik ins wanken
bringen könnten und das wäre eine
revolution der physik aber von vorne mit
der hilfe des standardmodells der
teilchenphysik sind forschungsteams
weltweit in der lage die kräfte und
teilchen die unser universum bestimmen
zu beschreiten eine gute und etablierte
sache also doch es gibt einen großen
haken denn dieses weltmodell vom aufbau
der materie kann so einige phänomene
beim besten willen nicht erklären so
kann es bislang weder die dunkle energie
noch die dunkle materie erklären und
auch die frage warum es mehr materie als
antimaterie im kosmos gibt bleibt
unbeantwortet heißt also im klartext das
standardmodell der teilchenphysik ist
unvollständig und irgendetwas großes
bislang unbekanntes wartet mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit da draußen noch auf
uns die forschung geht also davon aus
dass es jenseits des standardmodells
noch teilchen und vorgänge geben könnte
die bislang im verborgenen geblieben
sind die hoffnung auf eine neue physik
ist also groß und zudem auch berechtigt
die offenen fragen sind existenziell
warum existiert unser universum
überhaupt warum haben sich materie und
antimaterie beim urknall und sich
gegenseitig ausgelöscht warum gibt es im
weltraum deutlich mehr materie als
antimaterie
warum in aller welt existiert dieses
ungleichgewicht wie lässt sich die
dominanz der materie im universum
erklären was wir davon wissen und das
bereits seit 90 jahren jedes teilchen
hat ein partner ein antiteilchen quasi
doch wenn wir weiter schauen wird nicht
nur deutlich wie wenig wir bis heute
über materie und antimaterie wissen
sondern auch wie wichtig das
zusammenspiel von materie und
antimaterie ist denn beim urknall vor 13
8 milliarden jahren entstand heutiger
vorstellung zufolge genauso viel
antimaterie wie die uns bekannte materie
all diese teilchen im jungen kosmos
prallten auf entgegengesetzt gepolte
antiteilchen doch warum haben sich
antimaterie und materie nicht sofort
wieder vollständig vernichtet so wie es
eigentlich der fall ist wenn
antiteilchen und teilchen aufeinander
treffen die antwort darauf wissen wir
bis heute nicht doch klar ist das ganze
war wohl eine art kosmischer fügung denn
aus dem übrig gebliebenen bruchteil
sprich unser gesamtes universum ist nur
ein minimaler rest dessen was beim
urknall eigentlich entstanden ist
bildeten sich im laufe von milliarden
jahren sterne planeten und galaxien und
später dann eben auch wir menschen
astronomie teams weltweit gehen davon
aus dass ein subtiler unterschied
zwischen materie und antimaterie dafür
gesorgt hat dass ein teil der materie
überleben doch worin genau liegt dieser
unterschied warum gibt es dieses
ungleichgewicht im universum warum
bestehen sterne planeten und menschen
fast ausschließlich aus materie und
warum ist die antimaterie dagegen solch
ein exot welche subatomaren prozess im
urknall haben etwas mehr materie als
antimaterie
hervorgebracht fragen über fragen auf
die wir bis heute keine endgültigen
antworten wissen genau diesem rätsel auf
der spur ist auch das space experiment
am cern dazu stefan ulmer der selbst an
dem experiment beteiligt ist in einem
interview mit der dpa im kern geht es um
die frage nach dem ursprung unserer
existenz wenn wir die urknalltheorie und
das standardmodell der teilchenphysik
vereinigen gibt es eigentlich keinen
grund warum das universum entstehen
sollte zusammen mit seinem team ist
stefan ulmer auf der suche nach der
asymmetrie die ja offensichtlich besteht
die fachleute wissen dass antiteilchen
die entgegengesetzte elektrische ladung
der teilchen haben aus den materie
besteht in der theorie aber sollten
beide teilchen sorten die gleichen
eigenschaften haben und beim urknall
sollten zudem beide sorten in gleicher
menge entstanden sein in experimenten
zeigt sich auch wenn materie und
antimaterie aufeinandertreffen löschen
sie sich gegenseitig aus dass er ist die
erkenntnis zu dass eine asymmetrie
existiert doch woraus besteht diese
genau möglicherweise ja in der masse um
das rätsel anzugehen hat das base team
zwischen dezember 2017 und 2019 das
verhältnis von elektrischer ladung zur
masse von protonen und antiprotonen
vermessen und zwar mit einer rekord
präzision ganze anderthalb jahre dauerte
dann noch einmal die auswertung und die
ergebnisse dieser experimente wurden
jetzt im renommierten fachmagazin nature
veröffentlicht ganz einfach ausgedrückt
müssten bei einem zusammenstoß von
protonen und antiprotonen einige
protonen übrig bleiben vorausgesetzt
dass diese schwerer wären als ihre
antiteilchen bei den experimenten am
cern wurden einzelne teilchen in einem
rund 25 cm lang elektromagnetischen
container gemessen in der fachsprache
ist von der sogenannten penning falle
die rede darin kann ein einzelnes
geladene teilchen gespeichert und
nachgewiesen werden dass teilchen das in
der falle gefangen ist schwingt mit
einer charakteristischen frequenz die
eben durch die masse des teilchens
definiert ist das forschungsteam nutzte
das aus und hörte sowohl die
schwingungsfrequenz 'nen von
antiprotonen als auch die der protonen
in derselben falle ab so wurde es ihnen
also möglich die masse der jeweiligen
teilchen zu vergleichen dazu stefan
ulmer wissenschaftler der base
kollaborationen
durchgeladen eines zylindrischen stapels
mehrerer solcher penning fallen mit
antiprotonen und negativen
wasserstoffionen konnten wir einen
massen vergleich innerhalb von nur vier
minuten durchführen 50 mal schneller als
bei früheren protonen antiproton
vergleichen anderer gruppen seit unseren
frühen messungen haben wir außerdem den
versuchsaufbau technisch erheblich
verbessert das erhöht die stabilität des
experiments und verringert
systematischer verschiebungen in den
netzwerken innerhalb von anderthalb
jahren also war es möglich einen
datensatz von etwa 24.000 einzelnen
frequenz vergleichen zu erfassen die
analyse der messergebnisse zeigte dann
ein ganz klares ergebnis dass ladung zur
masse verhältnis von antiprotonen und
protonen ist identisch und das mit einer
genauigkeit von 16 teilen in einer
billion die genauigkeit der bisher
besten messungen die ebenfalls von base
stammt konnte mit diesem ergebnis um
mehr als ein faktor vier verbessert
werden ein riesiger erfolg also zudem
gelang ein zweiter vergleich die
auswirkungen der gravitation alle
teilchen egal ob materie oder
antimaterie werden von der gravitation
gleich beschleunigt so sagt es das
sogenannte schwache äquivalenzprinzip
das base forschungszielen wollte wissen
wie die protonen und antiprotonen auf
schwankungen reagieren innerhalb des
zeitraums des experiments umrundete die
erde die sonne mehr als einmal der
einfluss der anziehungskraft der sonne
änderte sich auf der elliptischen bahn
doch auch hier konnten keine
unterschiede im experiment offenbart
werden eine schlechte nachricht also für
alle die auf eine revolution der physik
gehofft hatten immer noch bleibt die
existenz unseres universums rätselhaft
antimaterie und materie sind absolut
identisch bis auf 16 millionen teile die
moderne physik ist also bislang nicht in
der lage die große frage zu beantworten
dazu stephan krömer wir haben mit hohem
mass präzision ausgeschlossen dass der
unterschied zwischen materie und
antimaterie auf einer differenz der
masse wird das standardmodell nach der
materie und antimaterie symmetrisch sind
bleibt also weiterhin bestehen muss die
hoffnung jetzt also endgültig begraben
werden doch noch das rätsel lösen zu
können nein der möglicherweise weisen
antiprotonen und protonen jenseits der
gemessenen werte unterschiede auf das
kann nach ansicht des forschungsteams
stand jetzt nicht ausgeschlossen werden
unterschiede bei den magnetischen
momenten sind denkbar und genau daran
wird derzeit bereits geforscht doch auch
hier gilt bisher zitat keine
unterschiede zwischen protonen und
antiprotonen so stefan ulmer das ist
wirklich ein bisschen deprimierend wir
wissen genau dass es etwas gibt was das
ungleichgewicht erzeugt hat aus dem
unser universum entstanden ist ohne
dieses ungleichgewicht würden wir nicht
existieren doch was ist es ukraine krise
hier so könnte helfen wir holen
flüchtende an diesem video liegt mir
sehr viel und ich würde mich sehr freuen
wenn es euch anschauen würde also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren bis
dann kann